new in chicago as mayor lawyer lori  lightfoot faces a lawsuit  over her policy of giving one-on-one  interviews only to journalists of color  a reporter with the daily caller says  that's a violation of  his first and 14th amendment rights a  statement from the city says  it has not yet been served with the  lawsuit  and this is a live look at new york from  our affiliate fox 5 one of the big  stories there tonight iranian new york  the transportation department gives  environmental approval  to a planned 11 billion dollar rail  tunnel that decision means the project  to build a new hudson river tunnel  connecting  new york and new jersey can push ahead  with engineering  and design work that's tonight's live  look  outside the beltway hey sean hannity  here hey click here to subscribe to fox  news youtube page  and catch our hottest interviews and  most compelling analysis  you will not get it anywhere else